foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
all right High gel
do the hugs fit how are you I'm good
okay
oh already 30 minutes ago already
neglecting her by not even standing up
to hug your life
[Applause]
by the way by the way just so you know
just so you're aware okay this this is
all this is all part of the show so
you're the show's happening right now
yeah I know okay I don't know
I walked in everyone's like I was like
oh they're like starting oh well no we
weren't we were talking about schedule
and stuff that's not going wow
you never know when I start the podcast
I'll probably start when Charlie was
playing this morning when I walked in
cool shirt Jill thanks Glenn Floyd now
between the two of you the amount of
band shirts that you own oh yeah now do
you guys do you buy them off people on
the side of the highway uh or do you
yeah is it online
it's not hard to find band shirts
I think this might be my only van shirt
right no you've got oh I have always
show you one okay yeah nice do you have
as many opinions on t-shirts as Glenn
does and the arms and how long as I
don't have as many opinions as one in
general yeah that would be quite a feat
an opinionated man any household can
only have so many opinions and I imagine
you gobble up most
yeah oh wow I gobble up most of the
opinion time let's give our our
listeners and uh our creeps a a proper
introduction of Jill
um
uh should we talk about your cat your
character first uh the fact that you're
married Where Do We Begin well first of
all I just want to say
I think it's like I mean you know the
creeps and the listeners they they've
seen a lot of Mary Elizabeth and and
Caitlin uh as actors but also they've
seen them on the podcast they they have
some idea of how we interact with
Caitlyn and Mary Elizabeth I don't think
anybody really has any idea
how we interact with Jill latiano Howard
it's true yes this is going to be more
you know
mystery life but I will say Glenn has
brought you up a lot in the most glowing
and loving terms so the rest of it we
cut out yeah
[Laughter]
um but we're also talking about the
Dennis system yeah we're really happy to
have you join us for this episode The
Dennis system which is a fan favorite
and you play such a crucial part in it
yeah it's funny we laugh all the time
because we cannot post a photo of
ourselves without all of the comments or
99 of the comments
just really works you forgot to separate
entirely we got to separate entirely
it's like hey guys okay so if any of you
are the ones that making that making
those comments any creeps and listeners
that are listening right now
I I get it I totally get we get it we
get it we get it I understand why you're
doing it but stop only but not because
not because we're offended by it or
anything like that just stop because
it's like getting old you know what I
mean it's like we get it we get it you
did it you can't make the same joke and
do they not see how many other people
are making the same joke yeah a lot of
like oh look I guess uh the waitress is
uh letting you hang around this week or
whatever yeah yeah yeah you get that too
yeah
separated entirely from our characters
please
yes I mean it's been cool yeah just go
back to commenting on Glenn's bleary red
eyes
Okay so it was seasoned oh yes okay so
thanks Charlie thank you
let's give us some structure uh the
dentist system is season five episode
ten it aired on November 19 2009 and
I've written down here that I believe
you two were married on September 8 2009
so this was shot before or after you got
it was shot before we got married
and we got married on September 5th I
don't know where oh sorry the internet
Wikipedia it just doesn't September 5th
September 5th um so you weren't married
yet no we were engaged it could have
gone wrong it could have been like so it
could have gotten out yeah
you know I've worked with you on set and
just I see now I see now the man that
you really are and I don't think I like
it now we had Martin Roselle in the
podcast and we were talking about the
Dennis system which was they penned that
they wrote it with David Hornsby Hornsby
and it was directed by Randall Einhorn
we'll have one at some point
[Music]
um
now
Recollections of
things
you're special you can't remember the
words
for how to remember things uh were you
do you remember reading the script for
the first time or did Glenn kind of
pitch it to you and say hey Glenn
probably pitched it to me I don't
remember I don't remember reading it for
the first time I don't if I'm being
honest is Jill close enough to the mic
guys yeah I believe so I'd be told
oh testing testing one two three Rob
likes to suck on it fully in his mouth
this one
um
we have to change your mouth though so
that's probably clean yeah great is that
better yeah all good
um where were we uh I don't remember
reading the script for the first time I
don't I remember like my general
recollection
well I just remember thinking it's
hilarious and insane and you know and
that it was gonna be super fun to work
together well we caught and we caught
Jill at a time where she was still
acting yes Jill is no longer acting
retired she retired from producing quite
a bit though yes producing a lot of
great documentaries yeah films yeah the
episode I mean Glenn and I watched it
last night I was just like oh my God
this is so [__] up have you had you
not watched it since it aired I don't
think so no maybe like maybe I caught it
once or two I don't know but not like
fully sat down to watch it you know I
don't know I don't love watching myself
I don't know some people are like that
it's kind of weird and so I think I
think most people yeah an uncomfortable
Factor there yeah but when we watched it
I was just like oh my god well she first
of all she was like we look so young I
did
yeah
you also put like a dreamy filter on
this sort of flash but it felt like when
you did the moments there was like a
little bit of like a yeah
maybe maybe yeah it was fun you look
awfully young sitting here in front of
me now so thanks Megan yeah it's been
about 14 years I think uh it has been 14
years it has been almost 14 years yes we
did that almost exactly 14 years since
we shouldn't that crazy yeah that's
depressing but I mean it's funny but
it's just so crazy I and I it made me
remember that at that time like when I
was when we were just dating before
married and people you know the show was
still young at that point and and they'd
say oh what does your boyfriend do and
I'm like oh he's an actor oh is he on
anything I would know I don't know do
you know the show It's Always Sunny in
Philadelphia like yeah oh yeah which one
is he and I'm like
I'm like he's I feel like he's the uh
psychopath vain [__] but I swear he's
not like that in real life you know
because he does it so well that I felt
like I'd have to explain like I promise
you he's just a really good actor that's
not who he is but there have to be
people out there that wonder why such a
wonderful person as yourself would be
married to such a horrible man not not
being able to fully separate themselves
from my character out of the fact that I
could be I could be a different person
you know or or that that I could present
in public as a different person than
than my character but there's got to be
deep down like is he the guy you know
what I mean but like I don't I mean we
we couldn't have been together for that
long if I was anywhere anything system
is so strong yeah
that's what I've always thought about
like self-help books when it comes to
dating is that a lot of them I feel like
especially geared towards women give you
a sort of like I remember I once got
this one called why men love [__]
I heard some cackles wow
um but it was all about how you need to
like treat him badly at the beginning so
that he'll like chase you but my thought
is always okay so let's say that this
system is like effective at what point
do you rip off the mask and go actually
it's me I'm really clingy independent
yeah
stitches you get that dissolve into the
skin
all right so maybe that was what
happened so slowly that you did
imperceptibly you didn't notice Yeah
Yeah by that time it was too late I
don't really remember that episode
getting pitched I guess we were talking
about those books those systems for
picking up women yeah I have a memory
of writing out the uh us writing out the
dentist system uh on the board in the
offices where we were writing season
four yes I feel like I can
I can read the letters on the board and
trying to come up with I remember being
in that space that we were in in season
four when when that acronym when we
first came up with the acronym and what
it all meant but I don't remember why we
weren't able to come well maybe we just
didn't have a story for it yet right
yeah we knew okay this is a funny
concept sometimes that's how it goes we
didn't have one of the right actress
you guys weren't even engaged You're
simply dating we didn't know if it was
gonna last we were engaged we got we
were engaged for a year and a half wow
yeah what was the hesitation there
wasn't you know what it was it was
Caitlyn and Rob were getting married
that year like and with four other
friends of ourselves so many other
friends getting married we're like we
gotta wait until the next year and then
I liked the weather in September and so
we're like we didn't want to we knew our
we knew our wedding was going to be
absolutely amazing and we just didn't
want to you know
it was a good time for me because I
would really cut loose at those weddings
you know foreign
but yeah so I I do remember I was coming
and then I guess we finally came up with
what the whole story was uh when we were
breaking season five which was at Fox
because season four
oh we were we were in Culver City that's
that's crazy yeah my whole
visual image of the writing of that
episode is is in the Culver City offices
so interesting right yeah okay so you do
so you do remember yes in the Culver
City offices yes yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah isn't it funny how like that's how
I remember things by the space we were
in totally no I mean I mean it totally
makes sense yeah yeah which is why like
five through
10 are such a blur because we were in
that those Fox offices forever yeah yeah
does that does become a little bit of a
blur five less so because it was our
first year there so like this season in
particular like really sticks in my
memory because it was the first year we
were at on the fox lot and I remember
and and who pooped the bed that that's
from this season right no that was for
last well that was four that was four oh
that's so weird because my memory of you
writing all that stuff out on the board
that's in those color city offices that
wasn't the Columbia City offices all
right so anyway back to you Jill what
else when did you guys
meat how did this happen I remember
hanging around the Venice house that
Robin Glenn lived at yes and every now
and then they would have a party and I
remember you were in the mix that's
where we met wait was Charlie at that
party I think he was
I think he might have been well I don't
know because I didn't know you yet
that's why it's not that you're not
memorable
or maybe you remember someone else there
was a lot of people there well the
gravity of Glenn was so strong that you
you only had eyes for him plus I was
taken so much
so we have uh we had a mutual friend we
have a mutual friend yada Martinez
um who Glenn went to college with and
who I became like quick friends with
when I moved to LA
and she brought me to their house party
I don't know if you want to say the
beginnings of that Glenn kind of asked
you want to tell your part well yeah
I've been single at that point and uh
for I don't know maybe two and a half
three years or something like that and
uh Jana and I were good friends and I
was like hey you know you got any got
any cute friends you want to invite over
here to anybody you think I would like
you know because we knew each other
pretty well and she knew I guess but
maybe what I would what I was into as
far as like what I was looking for
um and uh she was like you know it's
funny you bring that up there is this
one person
and then she described to me the per she
was and I was like oh tell me and what's
her name I did not sound good on paper
her name's Jill and and to me well in
some ways you sound amazing they sound
yeah but then in other ways I was like
and she was like she'll get it when he
said she was like her name's her name's
Jill
strike one
yeah
uh well my name's Glenn and Jill she
needs to have a cooler name
to balance
yeah uh but uh no and she was like she
was like she's a she's she just moved
here from New York
um she's a model
uh she's a dancer you know and now she's
acting as well yeah you know what I mean
and I was like and I was like three
things
where I'm like okay so she's she's
probably the track physically attractive
but like is she gonna be
yeah she did actually she did DJ she did
it
assistant okay yeah yeah yeah but yeah
on paper I get out kind of like douchey
I could have sounded or well I was just
I was just like or there's preconceived
notions of girls that you know are in
those businesses sometimes but I knew
that because you were friends with yada
and how much I liked yada and I trusted
yada's taste in human beings and I was
like okay well she was shot pretty
decent now wait sorry do you get Glenn's
breakdown were you also aware that the
setup was happening yes how was he
pitched to you he was pitched to me
you know what happened is I think we
were in the car with another friend and
they were talking about the show and it
was only season two so I hadn't heard of
the show yet okay and yeah it'd only
been I don't even know if season two had
aired maybe it had uh it had okay but
still very early and and they're talking
about the show and talking about the
guys on the show and then they were
talking about Glenn like oh he's cute
and this and I was like what is a show
who is this person you know and I unlike
Glenn had just got out of like a
five-year relationship so I was kind of
like ready to have fun and not looking
for something super serious but also I
was single I just moved to LA you know
so um she told me about him I probably
looked him up you know and I'm like okay
all right let's meet this guy yeah so on
paper I might not have looked that good
either then I mean no you looked good
you looked like a successful like
successful actor yeah he was amazing a
pretty big house he was a it was a
three-story
no you're You're missing two stories it
was it was no no one story but you had a
big room it was a big room it was an
apartment but it was a big apartment and
it was on the top floor of like a very
of like a two-story building or whatever
or three-story so you and Rob had the
top floor of that of that we had yeah
and jacuzzi on the roof with the jacuzzi
on the roof it was pretty Bachelor
patties yeah you got taken back to that
apartment with a jacuzzi on the roof and
you were like well you were I guess you
were in the place you're like well this
isn't going to be a long-term thing
like jacuzzi on the roof is not right
you know like wow
we craned it onto the roof if anyone's
interested
we literally had to get a crane yeah you
were like mac and Dennis creating a hot
tub onto
first of all first of all picture Rob
and I hot tub shopping
today the first step was going to the
hot tub place on Sepulveda and and and
and looking and looking at various
models and discussing the pros and cons
of the different shapes and yeah
it's gonna sit where and uh gloves one
pack right now if we have a quick
midlife crisis let's get an apartment
be a lot sadder now
[Laughter]
um
we've been going into to soak the things
that hurt you know
right it was just different motivation
being on that room yeah
yeah Rob's in a nice bath
you'd have to have a nice bed about that
Jacuzzi with ice okay so okay so we met
at the house party you made it the house
party and got past the whole jacuzzi on
the roof thing got past that we talked
about lots of interesting things yeah
yeah we had some we had we bonded over
the fact that Glenn had two cats I don't
know if everyone knows this when we met
he had two cats I grew up with cats I
liked cats and I had zero cats at the
time I had zero cats as a single woman
in my mid-20s good for you but I I did I
think what what we first started talking
talking was I heard him the cats one of
the cat's names was bean and my nickname
my friends called me Bean like Jilly
Bean like and bean for short so he's
like bean bean you know and I'm like
what and then I see he's talking to the
cat and I was like and I think I said
like I thought you were talking to me
because my friends call me Julie Bean or
Bean yeah and then we started talking
and he's like oh I have another cat he
had another cat in the other room he
showed me his other cat Okay so he
demonstrated talking about value with
this cat and his rooftop Deku yes yes
okay I showed her that I was in touch
with my feminine side yes I think he
rented those cats and then he was stuck
into keeping them because it worked
right you know no the funny thing is
like like on the surface very like maybe
to be considered like not that cool to
be like a single dude with with two cats
you know what I mean but the way but I
to my mind and by the way I was like I
wasn't single when I got the cats with
an ex-girlfriend and then we broke up
and I kept the cats and she left
um but so so I ended up a single guy
with two cats but I I decided at a
certain point I was like I'm gonna own
this like I'm gonna fully fully own this
and and embrace the fact that that I'm a
single dude with two cats you know what
I mean I I think uh
you're demonstrating your feminine size
yeah with your mask on the side it's a
good move so okay what's the next step e
engage physically yeah
everybody
you may have he started we're gonna
discover this and then I'm gonna yeah
let's see let's find out um so I didn't
demonstrate my value though that first
night with my hot tub but in the episode
Dennis doesn't even take Kaylee on a
date no so you dated at least we dated
you had some days we went on a first
date
something very shady happened on our on
our first date
um oh the money we were talking on the
phone I have no money
I've been to a lot of jacuzzi death
pray for this sushi but no I think what
happened is I told when we met and you
asked me out and I said oh I'm going to
Vegas that the next weekend for a
friend's bachelorette party yes so let's
hang out when I get back and he says I
said when I said I said all right tell
you what when you get to Vegas first
thing you're going to do is walk in the
casino
put a hundred dollars on black
right and if it pays
I'll take 100 and you take you take a
hundred right
but if if you lose I'll pay you back a
hundred dollars right I was like so so
you're you're right okay so I was like
so you're at no risk I like it you know
um and then and she lost
and so on our first date the first thing
I did so I walk up at the sushi
restaurant he's at the booth and he
hands me a hundred dollars looks real
good yeah it looks real good and they
were laughing about it
yeah
exactly yeah meanwhile yeah yeah I was
like that looks real bad
thank you
can I get a v can I get a u can I get a
o r i that's right it's a fiori oh hey
back to sponsor the Pod I love it yeah I
love my viewers yeah we love it viori is
a new perspective on performance apparel
all of their core shorts Sunday joggers
and activewear are designed to work out
in but don't look or feel like it wait
wait wait wait wait wait does that mean
that they don't look or feel like
workout clothes because uh I do want my
workout clothes to feel like workout
clothes you know what I mean yeah but
what mag is I think actually saying is
that you don't normally want to wear
your gym clothes out casually because
maybe
yeah well they aren't that comfortable
or fitted right could be the reason yeah
exactly Fiori's products are great for
running and training and overpriced
midday yoga classes for instance and
even swimming but they're also great for
just lounging around and running errands
and I don't have to get my uh workout
shorts uh tailored anymore you're
getting your workout shorts tailored
make it work when your workout hasn't
even begun to Peak viori is an
investment in your happiness for our
listeners they're offering 20 off your
first purchase so go get yourself some
of the most comfortable and versatile
clothing on the planet at viori.com
sunnypod that's
v-u-o-r-i.com slash Sunny pod and not
only will you receive 20 off your first
purchase but you will enjoy free
shipping on any U.S orders over 75
dollars and free returns that's a biggie
so go to fiore.com Sunny pod and
discover the versatility of Yuri
clothing
[Music]
thank you
when do you bring Glenn Howerton to San
Diego to meet your parents or your
parents come up to meet and meet him and
no no it was my sister's birthday yeah
my sister was living in Orange County at
the time and she had a big it might have
been her
I don't know how old were we I mean it
was our 30th or 30th yeah her 30th and I
brought him to that and what did they
think had they seen the show were they
like okay I don't think they'd seen the
show
her dad okay so her sense of humor comes
from her dad yeah all right so I just I
okay so I go to this thing and I go to
this this party which is basically just
a family party yeah me like a handful of
my sister's friends and like a family
yeah that was it um but like I got along
with all of them instantly
um especially her dad who he and I just
are like we were so we have the same
sense of humor where the like we just
got along like super super well and um
we were at the bar we were gonna get
like a beer or something like that and I
was like hey you want to do a tequila
shot to her dad yeah yeah yeah yeah and
he was like yeah let's do it you know so
we did it tequila shop and then and then
and then like maybe 15 minutes after
that he busted out the karaoke machine
and was like we're gonna do karaoke and
I was like oh [__] this family gets
crazy
okay so
a couple people got up did some karaoke
I'm sitting next to her dad on the couch
okay this is a true story yeah I'm
sitting next to her dad on the couch
and his song came up his turn came up
right the song Started he's like he's
like and he turns me and he's like oh
it's it's my turn I'm gonna go I'm like
oh yeah yeah go go and he literally gets
up and as he's getting up he farts on me
audibly like super loud and totally on
purpose like it wasn't it didn't squeak
out no just as he's lifting he was like
just like fully farts on me oh my God
and I was like that is the funniest
[__] thing like I've just met this
guy so wow and he just territorial in a
way this is the father this is the man
who raised her yeah and he would do
things like that he would just he's a
car salesman right yeah and he was like
the life of the party's a great athlete
he's an awesome golfer we would often
talk golf is amazing yeah and uh and you
you sense that had his life taken him
that direction he would have loved to
have been a performer totally right like
he's super charismatic like walked in a
room and just like radiated you know and
you're like like a big kind of strong
Connery kind of energy you know
um yeah but yeah that's his sense of
humor but then like interesting to get
farted on
like intentional I couldn't believe it I
don't know how I would I like it like
yeah
remember you're beneath me yeah yeah
yeah yeah remember don't forget I might
be having fun with the undoing shots but
don't forget your place yeah yeah yeah I
don't know I know he was like a
it's like a frat boy trapped in an adult
man's body you know yeah that was his
sense of humor I mean he did that to me
in high school I told I told our son
miles story recently because whatever
but I I he one time the phone rang oh I
was telling miles how like back in the
day when you called someone's house like
you had to like talk to their parents
and be like I'm gonna talk himself you
know
um and he's like that's awkward I'm like
yeah I want to hear awkward my dad
answered the phone once he's like hello
the person was like is Jill there and
he's like yeah hold on a second and put
the phone to his ass and farted in it
and it was my boyfriend
[Applause]
so this was like a move he did I guess
he thought it was hilarious to make
these things
and they stick around there's a good man
if they think this is funny then they're
a keeper I don't know well so if they're
offended by my casual flatulence uh you
know they're not gonna make it like but
if I can blast ass all over this guy
he's cool
anyway but the thing is is like you know
there's some people who can get away
with certain jokes and there are other
people who can't like if you don't know
Bob latiano you don't you don't you you
don't know if he's the kind of person
who can get away with something like
that who coming from another person it
would have been just disgusting
disrespectful strange and awkward but
coming from him just I mean I just knew
I felt like I knew him almost instantly
he just had that personality you just
like and and he could just he was the
type of person who could get away with
something like that and it was genuinely
funny
thing too with
men who've had raised two daughters
right who suddenly
you know there's this man in in the life
to be like ah like it's kind of like
enjoying the guy energy of it yeah I
have this a little bit with you know
Mary Elizabeth's father where I think
they like you know they didn't have a
son but and he didn't have a brother he
was an only child you know he's like a
sports guy he's just like he was very
sporty and jocular yes exactly and I
think he he just enjoyed that sense of
humor and he was silly but when things
like that happen you suddenly have
permission to just be fully yourself in
a weird way yeah you're like oh this
okay you can let it all hang out with
these people like that's a good feeling
to feel like you can be your authentic
self and that you're not going to be
misunderstood you can you can let your
full sense of humor your You Can Let
your freak flag fly you can find your
inner mantis toboggan
and just and just kind of go for it I
mean let's talk about that let's talk
about Dr mantis toboggan
um which is such a big part of what
happened without a doubt Rob martyr and
Roselle uh name There's Something About
the Name mantis that I remember Roselle
I think was had latched on to that as as
a word so did you think of the full the
full name mantis toboggan and then you
went back and inserted it into the
dialogue because because Max says he you
should see him Feast he's like right and
then he's like I liked that and so then
he takes that as the name so I wondered
if that was done organically in the
script writing or if it was thought of
at the end like we want him to be this
guy named mantis toboggan so you can't
remember that I think it was I think the
name came first honestly yeah and then I
think it was a way to organically have
him you know realize anything although
it occurred to me I was like so he's
been signing scripts just as Dr toboggan
and he he hadn't created a first name
for his doctor character yet until that
moment yeah and in that moment he
realized like that's the first name I've
been searching for yes yeah
video because I remember bitching
pitching like video hey Danny will you
say Dr deboggan and then remember your
first name's mantis mantis yeah and he
did it in such a funny way
take it from me
I am a doctor doctor toboggan
mantis toboggan
[Music]
but that mantis discussion is very close
to my favorite line of the episode which
is Danny saying I got my Magnum condoms
I got my wad of hundreds I'm ready to
plow yeah
I'm not realizing until this moment
right now that I forgot to re-watch the
episode oh you did I forgot you forgot
to watch it I forg just it skipped my
mind but I'm excited because now I get
to I get to go back and watch it I
completely forgot about your storyline
what is it what is my story you're
trying to Dennis the waitress yeah oh
and I go over a master plumbing up yeah
yeah
yeah Brad Carter yeah yeah also an
amazing musician he's a good actor
there's a great there's a really crazy
video of him getting like very serious
brain surgery
while he's playing the guitar what yes
[Music]
make sure they're not going near that's
right that's exactly right yeah they'll
have people play like the violin they're
taking around to see if they can you
know trigger any new skills right yeah
right yeah if this guy handing them new
instruments they start speaking
Portuguese you know right we're doing
something wrong I love this episode
actually because you think it's going to
be a very Denison trick episode and it
kind of is but what I like about it is
like your major want for the episode is
that you want to be understood by the
gang that your system works you don't
even he's not his want his characters
want isn't even to get the girl no he
doesn't care about that at all the
system works for the rest of you and
then the the it just has a great Sunny
um uh structure of that sending you all
off into these like little story lines
which are really fun to watch with like
you know Frank and his Amanda toboggan
and Mac trying to move it after Caitlyn
getting all paranoid that her boyfriend
is yeah
I like turtles we convinced yes we
convince her that Ben the soldier is
denising her sitting in that hot car
yeah it's just so sweet you're probably
getting Dennis right now by that new
boyfriend of yours and you don't even
know what boyfriend she don't have a
boyfriend
and you know the online soldier that I
met I went back together now what does
that not doing a date you after what you
put him through yeah maybe he does you
but he wouldn't date you he's not
denising me he's in the car right now I
told him to wait for me
[Music]
[Applause]
so wait is your guys been waiting out
here the whole time in the hot sun yeah
I just told him to wait for him and he
kind of just does whatever I say it's
pretty great why'd you tell him to do it
with the windows I know the engines I
didn't I didn't I just didn't tell him
to do it with the windows down he's not
you know the smartest it's like 100
degrees outside now I'm assuming that he
has engaged you physically well I mean
of course we've engaged physically look
at that body it is stupid of course
we've engaged over and over physically
but that doesn't mean that he's pulling
some sort of a system
hey guys hey
hey
I didn't see you there are you almost
done yeah yeah I just I got caught up in
a story but I'll be done pretty soon oh
oh okay do you want me to come in no no
I don't no you just you just stay where
you are and you know what I'll text you
when I'm wrapping up and then you can
crank the AC cool the car off for me
sure thing okay see you fellas okay okay
see you man D you're getting played
you're getting played big time doing big
time anything he's just I told him
and then it does also have a great Sunny
structure and then it just sort of ends
like it kind of gets up to a point and
then well you'll see this it just sort
of no no I I recall I I think there
might have been a couple lines past it
that we just cut we we we leave it on um
yeah am I gonna get a ride home so
sometimes we you know we have those
endings and they just
they feel wooden or they feel like super
scripty and so it's just better to find
out depending on Gladys 100 years old
when she shot this episode oh she's so
wow
I think the best version of finding an
ending that wasn't in the script was um
it's Seasons later but it's a water park
episode where it ends with Max but on
the on the thing we had a whole thing of
us going back to the car oh yes and
recall a conversation about it yeah like
what went wrong and it just it just felt
clunky when we got in the editing room
and then just ending it on Rob he even
kind of like looks in the camera a
little bit yeah he basically looks right
into the camera yeah it's actually
perfect there's her in there one of my
favorite moments is this is the first
time we see Dennis's sort of flashback
as Dennis is describing his system and
for and the first time we see you yeah
and uh and you get this sort of like
flashback feeling to it where they're
mouthing the words that they're saying
but urinary getting it yeah and then you
just look straight into the lens which I
think is really really funny and kind of
sets the tone for how like creepy this
is what he's doing yeah I demonstrated
my value to her by filling a
prescription I told her it's for my
grandmother she's quite ill thus
demonstrating my value as a loving
grandson and an all-around great guy
I don't know about what the time frame
was for when you started dating but do
you I was we were talking about the
other day the game the thing this this
episode is based on do you remember ever
feeling like you were the victim of like
the game being done on you like the
negging or any of that sort of do you
remember that that were you dating then
you said you were in a five-year
relationship before yeah yeah yes yeah
yeah she might have missed the game
window man it was weird yeah yeah so you
were saying you you experienced someone
trying to the game you oh yeah I I
experienced the peacocking I started
seeing that and because this that was
like in the book came out in 2005 and
2006 to 2009 I was in New York just like
dating and just kidding in my early 20s
and just yeah what was the peacocking
like what like wearing weird things like
you talked about your buddy like they
talked about
um having friends
had wearing strange things like coming
in with like a bird on the shoulder or
something like like that but also just
coming up and having pickup lines that
are really random like how often do you
wash your towel your bath towel or like
just these weird things throwing people
off balance right right like becoming
becoming a person of interest by
peacocking yeah and then having
interactions with people where you throw
them off balance and then they have they
can't they don't have time to
recalibrate before you've you've like
you tell a woman oh I I really love
those shoes you're wearing I think I saw
another woman wearing them and so you're
kind of complimenting her but also being
like you're basic that's fantastic
you're also a basic [__]
did you see um yeah you guys saw
licorice pizza right like uh the
character Bradley Cooper's playing is um
the famous guy who's like a hairdresser
turned movie producer who dated uh
Barbra Streisand like anyway he had a
pickup line that he you know Paul Thomas
Sanderson had written the script and
he'd asked him hey can I you know
represent you in this film this is okay
and he was like you know I wouldn't be
yelling at the the girl from Haim I
would be trying to sleep with her he's
like oh that's much better and he's like
hey can you get my pickup line in the
movie he's like what's your pickup plan
he's like I would just ask girls if they
like peanut butter sandwiches
and they would think that was a random
question and they would laugh at it and
then it would kick off a conversation
more like an icebreaker I feel like good
I like that so yeah you like peanut
butter sandwich yeah yeah I mean that's
that's it's got nothing to do with like
hooking up with them yeah it's not gross
or like how often do you wash your
towels is creepy yeah that's really
creepy yeah yeah but that is yeah you
like peanut butter sandwiches is just
perfectly normal yeah
did you ever have pickup lines what do
you think definitely not definitely not
no Charlie was just waiting and waiting
and waiting for her to make it very
clear that she wanted him to approach
him to start a conversation yeah uh and
that was yeah I don't know I would not
like I definitely would just
it used my sense of humor right like if
we're hanging out meet someone start
joking around the way I'm always joking
around and if they didn't like my jokes
or understand what I was talking about
adios you know yeah yeah that's pretty
good so it's pretty clear indication
this ain't gonna work
attention New York City hello New York
City talking to you hello are you there
we have another exciting announcement
the Always Sunny podcast is coming to
you live for not one but two nights at
where two Radio City Music Hall that's
right Radio City Music here's the thing
our October 12th show it's sold out you
can't go you waited too long uh whatever
60 seconds it was in which it sold out
and and now you need us to do a second
night but guess what we are doing a
second all right we'll do a second it
turns out New York is a very big city
and there are lots of people who'd like
to come so we're gonna do that second
night on on Friday October 13th pre-sale
begins this Wednesday at 10 A.M Eastern
with the code Sunny before the General
on sale Friday at 10 A.M eastern time
because you live in the East we also
have a live show at TD Pavilion at the
man in Philadelphia on Saturday
September 23rd so if you can't get a New
York City ticket maybe you get on a
train you go see that's right but don't
wait don't wait okay tickets and all
info at the alwayssunnipod.com
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
this episode like uh Max swimming in in
your wake and then Frank swimming in his
wake and how Frank says that one thing
he wants to do is move up a rank so he
wants he's trying to rise to get seconds
and go in front of Mac he's doing The
Bookworm routine with the with the
reading glasses Outdoors at the fair
which I thought was really a funny
choice to be like oh smart people wear
these but they're not recognizing that
they're for reading and yeah it's very
flipping the Magnum and monster in the
end where he says I dropped my um I
couldn't get it my monster condom
which wasn't an accident I think we
scripted it like that I can't remember
if it or it was either I think he
screwed it up in the rehearsal or
something or is there something really
yeah I think it was one of those like
Danny accidents that were like yes that
yeah that one in the same way that you
know that one the guy in 100 baby said
uh you know oh yeah don't get your
panties
of mistake perfect we're like that is so
much funnier than don't get your panties
in a wad yeah well also in this episode
sorry uh the uh Charlie you know tries
to Dennis the waitress and there's a
great Charlie line that I love I'm a
plumber you're a fair worker we go well
together
well together that's funny yeah yeah
yeah yeah I think we laughed at that I
feel like that was probably an
improvised line I feel like that was one
of those things where you guys are just
playing on the day another we had a real
speed pitch thing there oh yeah I
remember like trying to like throw
seeing how fast and like hurting my
shoulder already back then oh and also
just being bummed out at like how slow
it was like I was like I have no I never
had a strong arm but just be like oh man
I'm like maxing out at like mid 50s it's
terrible I really enjoyed that sequence
too because Charlie is like what what is
this and she just has to read off the
board like the very big letters that
says speed yeah
where do I win she's like I think that
was her improv yeah yeah
pitch
[Laughter]
or improvised I
love is Dennis coming up with how he's
going to fix the plan with that
classical music
okay clearly none of you have any idea
how to run my system God damn all right
I'm gonna get everybody what they want
including myself let me just think for a
second let me let me just work something
out here and then
well
what's he doing just shut up and let him
work
[Music]
we're going to the fair
that was an editing room Discovery I
think that was something that I think
that wasn't on the day
thing I I think I just I thought like
wouldn't it be funny to like
you know have some sort of like
orchestra playing in my head where I'm
literally orchestrating a plan as an
orchestra is playing and I I don't know
I think you go through all of that and
then you just say we're going to the
fair
which has already been put forward do
you play it drier do we do music and
then cut it out no we put his music yeah
yeah okay yeah it's great did you have
that in your mind when you were doing it
that I don't because in some matches
pretty well like what you were doing to
that song so I don't know if they had to
find a song to the match or yeah I think
I did I think it just worked out somehow
that's funny which is weird you'd be
surprised like how often things fit you
put it in just sometimes right it fits
so good you're like oh perfect right
right but yeah but it does end perfectly
on that
and I go like that well that wasn't
editing it's crazy yeah I don't know if
maybe maybe we could just put the timing
yeah
um how was it to act with one another
have you done had you done that before
or have you done it since uh in all in
all those scenes you had together uh uh
I don't think we have done it before or
since I mean no we used to work on
auditions with each other yeah but
that's different no projects that we've
worked on together no you've produced
things that Glenn's been a part of but
like uh yeah yeah I just recently yeah
that's correct the the thief collector
was a great documentary that she
produced and Glenn is in some of the
reenactments yeah he starts in our
reenactments with a very fantastic
mustache yes they're very kind of quirky
stylized reenactments
um that was just released last Friday
yes yes
Amazon iTunes Google Play can we talk a
little bit about the transition that you
made from being an actor to being a
producer and yeah like how that happened
and what kind of stuff you're working on
right now yeah of course
um yeah it's interesting I I was always
kind of Performing I grew up dancing you
know since I was three years old and
that transition in my early 20s when I
moved to New York I was a Nick City
dancer for a short time and then I
got into modeling from that and then I
did that for a while and then I started
doing commercials and I'm like oh
acting's fun and so I transitioned into
acting I talked about a commercial you
did with Tom Brady is that right I did
do a commercial I talked about in the
podcast I'm not sure if it ever made it
but I did and you can find that uh on
YouTube I think it's out there as a Visa
commercial with Tom Brady yeah we'll put
it right here yeah are you guys can
watch it watch right here yeah Tom we're
figurative metaphors what we represent
the five layers of Visa security to
surround you in a pocket of protection
hi there
yeah so it you know it was evolving and
kind of always trying to find the thing
that was my thing you know and I enjoyed
every
piece of that Journey but even as an
actor like I enjoyed it when I was doing
it but anyone that acts and knows that
it's a very or can be a very difficult
Journey you know it's like a lot of
waiting I felt like I was waiting for
something because it's like you work and
then the job's over and then you're
auditioning auditioning and auditioning
oh it's between you and one other girl
oh you didn't get it it's like this
roller coaster I think I tested I
remember hearing you talk about this one
so many times you tested like before
Sunny oh my God I tested I remember
seven times in one year for the leads
and pilots and didn't get any of them
and it was just like so rough you know
and
although I enjoyed it I'm like I just
feel like I have more to give and I'm
just like sitting here like I need to
put this energy into something and so we
Glenn and I enjoyed documentaries and we
had reached out to a director of a doc
that we saw that we really liked and I
said look and I just started putting it
out there I'm like if you need help with
anything like this is an issue I really
care about you know let me know and I
started doing work with non-profit
groups and environmental groups and
um and that director who we reached out
to she was doing this um
these celebrity PSAs for prop 37 which
was to get GMOs labeled this was back in
2012 and she calls me out of the blue
and she goes hey you know I'm doing
these PSAs and I was wondering you know
I know you haven't produced before but I
was wondering if you want to produce
them for me and I think at the time she
was asking because I had a lot of
connections with actors that shoot you
know like it would be easy to kind of
like cast and get people in and I'm like
oh okay I haven't done this before but
sure
and through that process I was like oh
like this is my thing like I just
enjoyed it so much like my natural skill
set is that of a producer and so it
doesn't feel like work to me and then
couple it with an issue that I cared
about it was like this is amazing and so
my now producing partner Josh
um he was also producing that those PSAs
with me and he had started another
project which is called GMO OMG which
was a full feature doc about GMOs and
he's like look it's just me and my best
friend who is the director and we've
shot it but we haven't edited it we need
some new blood like I know you're new
but I can tell like you're great at this
would you want to come on and help
finish this movie and I was like yes and
so it just kind of took off from there
and then Josh and I had such a good
experience on that movie that we decided
to start our company Roots Productions
and it's just been growing from there
it's amazing when you have that moment
right the spark where you're like oh
this fits this is right yeah I know you
don't feel like you're pushing the
boulder up a hill yeah I saw it it was
really interesting to see happen too
because I could see that she was
searching for something like this that
is like I have like she would say like I
feel like I have so much more to give
right um so much more to offer the world
um and
just couldn't quite figure out what that
was and it wasn't until she got involved
in GMO OMG that like I really saw like
this I saw you light up yeah and I could
see I was like oh okay this is yeah and
I think because I'd always been in like
the Performing Arts like I guess I never
even considered it really but then once
I got into that role I was like oh no
this is it you know and all the
experience I have from being a performer
helps me so much because I've been on
sets I've been you know like I feel very
comfortable in that setting I've seen
how producers work how they interact
with Talent how they you know like so it
was amazing how it just kind of like I
was like oh my gosh this is it this is
what I'm supposed to do so after after
GMO OMG you guys produced The Devil we
know yeah we went on to do the devil we
know
um and then the thief collector was next
the thief collector was the first DOC we
did that was not issue based it's just a
fun quirky art Heist film also about
like a very interesting couple a very
interesting yeah so it's like well it
became about that yeah it started out as
this you know basically a decooning
painting was cut out of the frame in
1985 at this tiny Museum in Arizona and
they had no video like security cameras
or anything so it kind of disappeared
into the desert and then cut to 32 years
later this 85 year old woman passes away
her husband and died a few years earlier
a small town in New Mexico like 300
people and they find this painting now
worth 160 million dollars hanging behind
their bedroom door crazy just to do
something like that and then to never
tell anybody about it well they were
they were School teachers well that's
what the whole documentary is about it's
about it's exploring did they know what
it was did they because they were
deceased so like there isn't full full
proof that they did it did they not do
it did they purchase it you know all
these things there's a lot of evidence
in the film as you'll see that well you
know it points to them actually doing it
themselves but but
how how did two School teachers become
like art thieves
and why they don't sell it they don't
like profit off it no it's purely for
Russian like how well they're knowing or
maybe the sense of like having some sort
of power and like a yeah powerless life
yeah it's really interesting and how the
people in their lives would never have
guessed in a million years that they
would could be capable of something like
this like it's it's fascinating couples
that commit crimes together are just
interesting because like it's I always
think it's so hard to meet somebody that
jives with you on so many different
things yeah but like imagine if you
found somebody that was like no I
literally I also want to kill people
yeah and what are you working on now or
are there projects that you're working
on that you can talk about yeah there's
a handful I can't talk about yet but um
I guess the next one the one we're
working on now two things were in
production on one is a four-part doc
series for MGM plus about the serial
killer Ed Gein oh interesting it's not
it's it's outside like
pull up Shades that's why it's a little
ironic that the wife of Dennis would be
yeah producing a doc about the guy who
makes skins like I've made so many jokes
that were all based on my knowledge of
Ed Gein only because I remember seeing a
movie and by the way I got [__] up
just to call them Circa like serial
killer slash designer yes
DJ
but I'd seen a movie about Ed Gein years
ago and I was just I was like oh my this
is the most [__] up [__] I've ever and
like and the thing that really stuck
with me was the fact that he would take
people's skin and like turn it into like
lamp shades yeah and you know and so and
so that became a source of Comedy yeah
for like my characters like he's saying
do you think that if somebody made a
mask of my face
all those jokes and then in the in the
the podcasts thing that we did where you
know I talk about like turning someone's
into a lampshade or right and then in
the episode where I'm talking to Dee
about oh yeah
a luggage collection
yeah so it's very ironic because it's
really not the subject matter is not in
our wheelhouse it's we've never done
true crime or anything but there's a
really
unique aspect to the show that hasn't
been announced that I'm not allowed to
talk about but stay tuned because it's
something that are organic lamp shades
let's make it uh
different than any other show or movie
you've seen about it well first of all
most people don't most people don't even
know that much about Ed Gein there have
been so many things about other serial
killers but he was like
the psychology behind what he did is
really interesting like he's not a
charismatic Ted Bundy type he's like a
very simple farmer but he had a very
complicated relationship with his mother
and so the skin suit stuff is like
trying to recreate they think she is
maybe trying to recreate his mother like
it's very what a lot of for those people
who don't know much about Ed Gein uh
Leatherface is based on Ed Gein
psycho that character in Psycho is based
on Ed Gein signs of the Lamb silence
yeah Hannibal Lecter is based on like so
many of those like horrible characters
yeah we're based off are based on Ed
Gein and yet people don't know that much
about it again and this this stock has
like as she said like an element to it
that is it's going to be surprising I'm
not allowed to say it yeah but it's it's
all right new discoveries yeah um yeah
so that one that'll be out in September
I believe we were thinking Halloween but
I'm thinking it's going to come out
after Labor Day so we'll see
um and then
yeah we're in production another feature
talk about domestic workers
um and their fight for
protections under federal labor laws and
dignity
um you know uh there we like to say that
not we I should say ijinpu from the
National Domestic workers Alliance
coined this phrase which is so true that
domestic workers make all other work
possible you know women like me would
not be able to be in the workforce if it
weren't for domestic workers for our
nannies and you know Home Health Care
aides that take care of our elderly and
are disabled so it's about
um
that group of mostly women not all women
mostly women of color immigrants so
that's a really
important story that I'm excited to be
working on and then we have a handful of
other things in development and we've
kind of organically gotten into scripted
because I'd be looking for stories for
docs and kind of read things that are
like this would be an amazing movie so
Glenn and I are actually speaking of
working together we're producing a
scripted movie together great I don't
think this is how those things seem to
find their way around like you say
you've retired from acting but I
wouldn't be surprised if it found its
way all the way around until you make a
scripted thing that you're like you know
what I want to be in this yes you're
acting again you never know I I don't I
mean maybe maybe it came up it came up
even when we were working on the thief
collector of like should we be in this
together like do you want to play right
we were casting the woman you know and I
was trying to get different actresses
and well I did say I'm like if we can't
get who we want I will do this you know
everyone's like just do it and I was
like I will but I didn't really want to
yeah that was the thing that was
interesting I'm kind of done with it I
mean if someone had something that was
just right or it was like a funny Cameo
or like if they asked me to like for
Kaylee to come back for an episode like
yes I would do that but like oh that's
interesting but I'm not looking I'm not
looking for that so I I enjoyed
separated I've separated entirely yeah I
really have that's fine but yeah but
it's fun it just makes it want you so
much more yeah you know that's been
proven yeah and your marriage It's Gonna
Last
well the kids are driving you nuts and
and uh there's there's no telling
there's no there's no telling I mean
there's all kinds of things that can you
know ruin a marriage
but for now we're bonding over the skin
lips um
I think we did it yeah we did do it
but it was what do you think of being on
the podcast I enjoyed it okay I did
enjoy it into please separate separate
entirely